[Music]
Northwest steals the show at Kim
Kardashian's baby shower the 37 year old
reality star may have pulled out all the
stops at the recent cherry blossom
themed events I mean check out these
flower petal ice cubes but it really
doesn't get much cuter than little nori
who appeared to be in cherry blossom
heaven sporting an adorable purple
kimono with matching fuzzy slippers as
she posted up amongst the gorgeous
flowering trees North will soon have
another sibling with Tim and her hubby
Kanye West expecting their third child a
baby girl via a surrogate I love her
it's the best relationship with my
surrogate she's so nice she's the
perfect person to do this for my family
but as Kim explained to the ladies of
the real her surrogate was not invited
to the shower of course I would have
wanted her to be there and be a part of
it but I I hadn't really gone that far
and explaining it to my kids yet so I
have to figure that at first earlier
this month
Kim opened up to et about adjusting to
using a surrogate I think it's so much
harder to go through it this way because
you're not really in control and you
know obviously you pick someone that you
completely trust and that you have a
really good bond and relationship with
but it's still knowing that I was able
to carry my first two babies and not you
know my baby now that is hard for me so
it's definitely a harder experience than
I anticipated just in the control area
[Music]
you
[Music]